uh has watched only basic anime but says
they are a uh says they are a weeb has
watched basic anime only watched basic
anime and says they're a weeb
okay um
okay sure I didn't know have to think
about
it I
mean there's only one answer
right okay ready 3 two 1 I feel green
we all disagree yes bro I don't give a
[__] this this just shows our
personalities Joey is like anime
mentioned red flag I think there are a
lot of very popular quote unquote basic
anime out there where you could actually
be a weeb now and have only watched like
the well-known shows I think you can be
into the anime aesthetic and everything
that like about anime without needing to
watch serial experim experiments Lane
okay but here's the thing this is this
is the insinuation that you use the word
meme in uh weeb in a positive way well
what okay I guess that's also a tough AR
mean referring to yourself as a wee I
guess I mean that you know I'm I'm more
like focusing on the kind of anime side
that paper could have just said calls
themselves a wee it still would have
been I guess it's kind of not a it's not
a great argument but I think that it's
one Okay the reason I put green is
because I literally uh have met somebody
that's went through this exact scenario
like a Hassan huh l and H no no it's
it's uh it's a friend who's not uh he's
not you
know he's not on social media yeah he's
not on social media green flag by
basically they they they met a person
and this this person put in here was one
of my close was one of my close friends
and they're a massive weep right they
they went up through like they went
through the phase where they kind of did
the did the anime man thing where they
watched every anime that came out in a
season for like years on end that's
[__] uh and then they kind of burnt
out of anime sure and uh it's just like
me for real yeah they just like you for
real and they burnt out anime and they
just stopped watching anime for a long
time kind of went on with life got a job
and then they met their current partner
who was like actually I'm a weeb I've
watched my hero Academia and and one
piece not knowing that there's like a
secret level 99 weeb standing right next
to them
and you know part of the bonding session
that they had and part of the reason why
you know they kind of really got close
together was because she got to uh
introduce them to a bunch of anime uh
not
realizing not like and not realizing
that you know they had they were a
really really big wee is is is one piece
considered Normy now yes oh
100% it is it is very very nor so you're
you're a Normy if you watch such an a
horrible word if you watch One Piece
you're making sure okay why did you have
to put so much emphasis on the Nory Nory
yeah so like the way I the way I
interpret this that is that okay
enthusiastic yeah they they're
enthusiastic about anime and they've
only seen the basic anime so you have
the opportunity to be like the dichotomy
of men right you have the opportunity to
be like babe I can I can I can show you
the world I can show you the world babe
let me introduce you to a whole T of
defend gatekeeping okay I will I will
say that is a lovely story but that is
one very rare occurrence in my opinion
of it just happening to work out right
okay most of the time right quote
unquote weees who have only ever watched
my hero in one piece are not that open
to watching the weird [__] they're not
you don't need to watch the weird [__]
Joey well not should every weeb have
watched evang
gallion why Evangelion specifically it's
a great barometer for this kind of
question I think
well anime fans answer very differently
to this question um I think every anime
fan should watch AA not just to like can
they call themselves an anime fan I
don't think they need to of course they
can this is going back to the
12-year-old pal thing I don't think you
you need I didn't enjoy you don't need
to watch you don't need to enjoy AA but
you should watch it if maybe I'm
12-year-old yeah like I like personally
as an an fan I I I think every wee
should watch evangelon just to like have
an opinion on it it's one of those anime
where I'm like it's such a different
experience to everyone who watches
Breaking Bad of TV fans I would call it
that every like Breaking Bad is like way
too critically acclaimed you know is
Evangelion not it's very polarized I
thought it very critically Acclaim
though no I think I think it's
critically a claim for the people who
love the show but a lot of people do not
like the show and that's fine but like
okay I think for me the reason why it's
red is because I think the way that I
see and you know act you know act around
weebs or like talk to weebs is very
different considering my background okay
because like when whenever I think of
like a stereotypical wee like they don't
even have to have watched only the basic
[__] right they could be the most like
knowledgeable in anime but like when
they think that they know a lot about
like Japan or like they know a lot about
like Japanese just because they've
watched a couple hundred shows of anime
couple hundred yeah even a couple
hundred that to me is just racist
w w where are we going with this people
people who only watch anime consume
anime even the most basic [__] and just
think to themselves like yeah I know so
much about Japan I know so much about
Japanese in uh interpolating the
definition of weeb as being like
probably like um well I guess wee is
technically like a Japan yeah it's a
japanophile that's what a weeb is in in
the traditional sense and that's how I
do this that angle right like it would
like oh my God if Aki [__] came up to
me every day and started going yeah oooo
and then just started doing some like
maid noises [__] I would [__] kick
her out like that [__] would be so
godamn annoying and there wouldn't be
any room for talking about hey babe have
you watched Evangelion cuz I wouldn't
[__] even ask that
question I guess I guess if you're
Japanese is a bit different I
guess the plot TW of us talking about
anime and Joey just goes
racism I was just like oh my God it is I
mean I I yeah I'm not Japanese so I
can't take that argument yeah I mean
like like as a counter argument right I
think the like you're taking like I
guess the mid 2000s definition of like
wee I love that nucular response to it
that was great this is the kind of
content we need to keep this podcast
alive I'm I'm like somehow I have to
argue Against Racism here
but but hang on but hang on Joey okay
what is the okay okay admittedly yes my
definition of Wee is like the [__] yd
of Wee right what is the what what would
you say is the 2023 definition of Wee um
weeb is I I think like the English
language words always change and I think
wee has changed we doesn't mean somebody
who's Japan for me someone who has
watched a a lot of anime this this this
says someone who's only watched basic
anime yeah if someone's watched a lot of
anime they would never call themselves a
weeaboo unironically right because they
know about the anime culture when I
when I hear the statement has watch only
basic anime but says they are a wee that
means they are kind of just in the entry
level anime Community kind of thing that
that paper should say and says they're a
wee not but says they're a wee yeah I
mean I was kind of go hand in hand I
mean I I would say if you call yourself
a weeb um and you've watch any basic
anime you just probably heard that as a
buzz word somewhere on the internet
you're like okay you're Justa yeah
probably probably all right let's do
another take then all right all right
where do we go racis dude I can't wait
for the next
take you just waiting for my bombastic I
love it dude this is I I'm so glad
someone else is doing it for
once I don't swinging we need to keep
this podcast interesting all right next
take red flag green flag or beige flag
uh hasn't watched any classic
movies
uh I don't know how I feel about this
I'm a really big film guy you guys know
I love watching I think all three of us
love film I'm I'm a big film guy as well
we've all seen a lot of
movies so I think mine is pretty
straightforward yeah M mine's
straightforward as
well I just saw your answer G what the
[__] it's also it also depends on how
you define classic
movies as well Classic Movies Godfather
okay classic movies I'm going I am theb
top 50 all right ready 3 2 1 I said none
yeah none I don't think it's anything I
think it's whatever green yeah what the
[__] do you think it's good that they
haven't watched the it's a great trait
to have I I think it's a [__] great
trait just because you get to like like
it's it's very similar to the anime
thing where you get to show them
something and part of like part of
you're assuming that they're already
down to watch them now what if they're
not down to watch what if they don't
want to watch them that movie looks old
G yeah what if the reason why they
haven't watched these Classic Movies is
because years ago they looked at the
IMDb top 50 and they're like ah they're
all they look old and boring I mean that
that was not said on the piece of paper
to me if someone if someone you're
assuming that they are they they want to
watch them and they'll watching with
yeah g is very optimistic about
optimistic about all these problems okay
I'm super I'm super optimistic I can
change this I can fix them I'm I'm super
optimistic because uh I just love like
not even like with your partner but like
with any friends or family that I have
plenty of family members who you know
have not watched X thing or have not
experien X thing and part of that
especially if it's a partner I like to
me it's a green flag because I assume if
we're Partners right that part of part
of being a partner is that even if
you're not necessarily interested in a
topic that you're you know that before
you met your partner that you want to
explore it with them like for me I do
not give a [__] about horror movies for
example but I still will sit down with
Sydney and watch some horror movies and
I'm happy just seeing the stuff that
she's passionate about even though I'm
not I'm never going to be as passionate
about it right but again you're you're
looking at this like you know fictional
relationship that you have with this
partner as a very optimistic thing of
like they're just kind of down for
everything and the only reason they
haven't watched these Classic Movies is
because they''re just never given the
opportunity well why you why are you
being pessimistic Joey what's wrong with
being a little bit optimistic about
assuming God best of intention Joy
because life's a [__] it doesn't work
out that way it's not all candy and
Rainbow sometimes there are people who
are just so up in their own head where
they look at some they look at these
like movies like Godfather like
Apocalypse Now like Good Fellas and
they're just like oh it's old and it was
made before my time not interested I
don't care I'd rather watch the next
[__] Avengers movie watch the FNAF
film I'd rather watch the FNAF film you
know to to me if if if the paper said
that uh they watched a bunch of classic
films and they do not care for them that
would be like a different answer for me
what would that be for you
uh for me no for me that would be more
like more beige none you know like to me
that doesn't signify a relationship but
to me if I know someone has not seen the
same things that I'm interested in I see
that as an opportunity to be like oh
okay we can possibly bond together or I
can show you stuff that I'm passionate
about and I'm interested in and we don't
necessarily need to enjoy the same
things to have a good good working
relationship so because you could
reframe this with anything like um they
haven't read the classic books they
haven't read watched the K K drama
series the classics that's why I said
none though in this case because it's
like it can really go both ways and if
you kind of average that all out it does
become a nonf flag yeah I think it's
whatever like I think there's a reason
why you haven't consumed that media
there's lots of people ask I just like
to see the Gooden people I like to
assume the best guys like like it's
great because then I can share it with
them again that is
great all right all right pick one pick
one all sorry ladies GS taking
all right is gone just going to write
green for
everything all right what's the next one
G doesn't watch a show if it's
popular
okay all
right why are you guys laughing no
reason no reason Joey all right I got
mine all right 3
2 I mean I think it's a I think it's a
bad trait to have some might say if if
if you're just judging Things based on
its popularity uh then like you're not
coming into this with a open mind you're
coming in this with preconceived you're
just hater you're a hater yeah you're
just you're just a hater you know and
you think you have better taste and more
Superior tast I'm not speaking on behalf
of anyone but if I was someone like that
uh you think as an OD I think it's just
a bit weird weird and there's yeah I
think it's a red flag weird what if you
know we were dating Joey and I was super
happy to watch this new show called
Arcane with you and I was telling you
about how I was super excited for it and
you're like no we're not watching it no
I'll watch it like 5 years later no okay
well it's we're getting there okay do
you promise to watch Arcane in 3 years
no wait you just said you'll watch it 5
years later no just some amount of my
flag that's my red flag dude I'm
currently watching [__] stranger
things cuz I'm finally getting around to
finishing it and it's great all right
all right I'll pick all right all right
all
right well I know Felix has my back I'm
not the only one I'll say that to Felix
as well Joey it's okay